il ya benjamin mendy qui dit en slip et
il imite un animal on rigolait hier
matin que dis je m'occupe de lui demande
la raison de la hausse qui pénalise matt
barr a rédigé une proposition côté moi
bien parce qu'il est avec lille et quel
directeur
c'est un programme ça tu vas tu montres
ont faim pelouse a juste fini dit si
justement tu fais tout tu fais tu
préfères quoi commencer une pauline qui
n'est pas une poule où le crapaud alors
les mêmes eaux des rivières la poule ou
quoi et écoutez je sais qu'il va
apprendre à tricher voilà
[Musique]
j'en fais casting théo le cogneur de
tapper le niveau à la recherche d'une
embrouille tomber cette île
[Musique]
j'ai plein d'affaires ici je vais pas
passer des proches de m
il va faire de toi un trésor les
chiffres et il ya de tout il ya des
basques et biba torontoise et regarder
un petit chalet comme ça c'est le
sentier regardez regardez je te vois
avec sujet des taux je te vois avec ce
génie je te vois avec ce gilet tout de
suite bam
c'est très bien ça cher papa regarde moi
ce jean regarde moi il faut qu'on te
laisse toi aussi tu maire jean tu feras
une entraînement avec les bottines peep
prestement bottines j'ai hâte alors je
vais essayer de continuer et man tu es
bien dans ta vie
[Musique]